oh sorry was this seat taken
[Music]
Doctor Who series 11 episode 3 Rosa so
this I was very nervous about coming
into because let me be really blunt
about this I do not like historically
said episodes where the doctor and the
campaigns meet a famous person from
history I just don't I never really have
I there's very few of them that I like
it's only a handful
I don't mind historical episodes that
don't involve a famous person but the
minute that that gets integrated so
often these episodes become really just
weird and awkward and clunky and it
feels like you know a an attempt at
trying to make an educational special
fun you know cuz they're dropping all
these facts about the person or and
usually there's a very caricature esque
performance for the historical figure at
the heart of it I just generally don't
like these things so this one was a bit
different it's certain it avoided the
pitfall the potentially huge pitfall
that the premise of doctor and the
companions run into Rosa Parks has which
is that if they do the usual Doctor Who
thing and integrate a whole alien plot
into it and then the doctor and
everybody saves the day it runs the risk
of appearing to diminish what Rosa Parks
did and what she was because now
suddenly it's not the black woman who
refused to give up her seat because she
felt she as much as much right to it as
anyone else did and suddenly it's not
that anymore it's well yeah that's what
it looked like from the outside but
really it was aliens you know
and this doesn't really do that this
actually does a fairly impressive job of
not in any way diminishing Rosa Parks
and what she does and may it because
what the what the role that the doctor
in the companions are taking on here are
historical preservationist s-- they are
doing everything possible to ensure that
history happens as it was always meant
to but that doesn't mean going so far as
to like you know I actually do the thing
that the historical person did
themselves just to make sure it sounds
like no Rosa Parks still does it herself
she wasn't informed of the impact of
what it is she's doing so she's still
doing it for the reasons that she did it
originally not because she was told oh
it means this great thing you know by
you know this white woman that she
didn't know so you know none of that so
there's a ton of stuff that could have
gone really wrong all of which is
avoided and I think it makes it fairly
unique in terms of the historical
episode certainly of the modern era
where the historical person doing the
thing they are best known for kind of
goes on I was gonna say uninterrupted
the sort of the plot of this is an
attempt to interrupt it but the the
whole thing with the the idea that you
know she's she's doing what she was
always gonna do and we're just kind of
there is is a different way to play it
I'm not sure it's a particularly
engaging way to play it though the the
episode overall it didn't grab me very
much it's weird but I I thought about
this episode for a bit before recording
this a bit more than I had initially
planned on doing and I'm glad I did
because the more I thought I'm like you
know what on paper there's a lot of good
ideas here intellectually I liked this
episode because I don't always need the
world's at stake threat levels I don't
even know need you know the immediate
characters we like you're going to die
threat levels every
I dig something low-key from time to
time and like I said the the way to
approach this story in this era as they
did shows a lot of thought put into it
and I appreciate that yet at the same
time I wasn't grabbed so I don't know if
that is me and like my own aversion to
these to Doctor Who doing these types of
stories in general or if it actually
isn't especially engaging overall I
think the villain doesn't help
I kind of wish that like it had been
more of like just a cosmic something you
know like a cosmic domino effect you
know because the the only interesting
thing about this film weed so like what
I say cosmic domino effect I mean rather
just like something happened somewhere
else and it sent out ripples and this is
one we gotta fix it we got to be sure
that you know this bus driver and her at
this time this buzz this day you know
doing what they did but without an
actual external pretend antagonist
because he didn't he didn't help but
there is an interesting thing at play
with what it is he's doing which is the
idea of altering history with tiny
alterations tiny nudges tiny details and
then the domino effect of that resulting
in a complete different future that's
actually kind of an interesting idea
that the episode doesn't really do
anything with that I did just kind of
exist to explain why this guy isn't just
shooting you know Rosa Parks and or the
doctor and her companions so you know
they go through this whole thing about
the restrictions put in his head after
being released from a storm cage yeah so
so he can't just kill him and so this
he's doing this as an alternative and
you know all of that exists to explain
why it doesn't just kill people but it
even though that's all it's narrative
function is it's an idea that kind of
wanna see brought back and done better
done with more focus on that particular
idea
and the other thing I don't there's
something I can't decide what I think
about the Ville in terms of his
motivations because as far as we get his
motivations he's based in just a future
racist and he's trying to go back and
make sure that one of the big events to
kick off a massive part of the American
civil rights movement is stopped and and
not allowed to to move forward in the
hope that that will snowball into what
were his words you know you people
knowing your place or something like
that whatever he says to Ryan and like I
said I will varying mixed feelings about
that on the one hand I guess I always
kind of preferred the Star Trek look in
terms of the future and I know the
doctor who doesn't always deal with this
but it always throws me off when you
know we get something set in the future
and people are acting like folks did in
the 1950s that that can often kind of
throw me off now on the one hand I get
it because it's like you know these
problems haven't gone away you know from
Rosa Parks is time to when she did this
to now they haven't gone away why would
they have gone away in another hundred
thousand ten thousand fifty thousand
years why would they not still exist and
there's a validity to that but I think
part of the things that I don't like
about that is when you make characters
from the future in terms of their
motivations and their feelings about you
know the world as a whole so much like
figures from either modern or the for
the past it kind of remove it kind of
makes the fact that they're from the
future irrelevant it's like well what's
the point of even having a guy from the
future and the story if he behaves
exactly like a guy from the 1950s why
can't it just be a guy from the 1950s
who
whatever reason is acting out of time
you know his actions are distorting the
timeline but if he's motivated by the
same thing that this guy from however
far in the future is motivated by like I
don't know it just it's it feels and it
feels unnecessary in terms of the fact
that this guy is from the future it's
like well he doesn't behave any
different from some of them from no
recent more recent so what was the point
I don't mean like what was his point
within the story but I mean what's the
point of having him be from the future
of that maybe that's what throws me off
about that sort of thing I'm not
entirely sure I will I would really like
I was surprised the doctor didn't have
monitor Ryan for blasting the guy with
his own thing I know it wasn't a weapon
it like just sent him way back into the
past but I kind of want to see
consequences of that cuz that that felt
cuz I and again I know it's not like he
disintegrated him but the doctors
companion shot somebody
I feel like that's the kind of thing
that needs more acknowledgement if not
in this episode like that's a
consequence that should play out down
the road and I'm not sure it's going to
so that was another moment that was
weird the one who plays Rosa Parks she
looks the part
quite well she plays him pretty good too
the accent is a little weird I didn't do
research cuz I don't really do research
but I I'm going to assume that she was
working off of archived footage of Rosa
Parks on in terms of fara how the voice
worked because the accent was a little
weird and I don't mean like it sounded
like it was slipping like the accent was
just kind of weird and I'm going to give
the benefit of a doubt of the doubt and
assume that that was accurate to how the
woman actually talked so and so I'm
acknowledging it but also saying
probably not actually something that I
feel like criticizing but just on the
off chance that it's not accurate to how
she actually talked in which case yeah
then it's just a weird accent this feels
like it's from two different places same
hi the companions and the doctor were
fine you know grant and I'm sorry I'm
gonna keep saying Graham because if you
know I know I have British viewers who
get annoyed with me because I say like
an American but look dude I'm an
American I'm sorry if I try and do
Graham all the time I'm just gonna
stumble over it
he gets a bit of a highlight it's it's
interesting I'm Ken Taylor I like his
dynamic with Ryan I like them continuing
to try and bond I'm and mostly be able
to do it over memories of Ryan's nan
yeas still just kind of there for the
most part still waiting for her to show
a little bit more relevance the doctor
was solid you know she does the the
moral superiority the sort of you know
taking the high ground and saying what
you're doing is wrong and I and I get to
say things yeah she does that well
enough and she was fine that's kind of
this episode in a nutshell it's so like
it's better than I thought and then I
thought it was gonna be given the type
of episode it is and then specifically
what it was dealing with I was really
nervous about this I was really afraid
that it was gonna be a special kind of
bat it definitely wasn't but I don't
feel the need to rewatch this like ivory
watched the first episode ivory watched
the ghost Monument
I don't feel particularly impetus to
rewatch this one so and I mean as far as
the pictures of the 1950's go and you
know with a focus on race relations
that's you know I think pretty well
depicted pretty well handled all things
considered I have absolutely no doubt
that there's gonna be a certain stripe a
fan or a certain stripe of troll
masquerading as a fan who is gonna you
know be calling you uh Morris JW stuff
because they have to make it all about
race like well if you're gonna do
anything related to Rosa Parks of course
it's gonna be heavily tied into race
that's but she's famous for
with an addressing but and and to kind
of back up look I'll just clarify when I
say trolls masquerading as fans that's
not me saying that everyone who makes
those claims is a troll but I do know
enough to know that some of the people
who do that aren't actually fans they
are doing it because they want to get a
rise out of other people so you know
it's a mix but I I don't feel that this
is I don't feel this is agenda pushing
particularly it is displaying the agenda
of Rosa Parks from 60 years ago 70 years
ago holy cow no 60 I can't do math I'm
tired but you know it's not it doesn't
do a ton to obliquely tie it to any
recent events it's depicting this
historical event that people learn about
in school and aside from the
time-traveled mists of it's at least so
far as I as I know of the incident
depict you pretty well but again it just
it just didn't grab me especially it was
fine that's kind of where I leave it at
this one so that wraps up my thoughts oh
one last thing
was it a misunderstanding cuz I thought
I remember that when it was said that
the season was only gonna be 10 episodes
long that the episodes were gonna be an
hour long I remember that being a thing
was that just a miscommunication because
right now only the first episode was an
hour long this and the one previous
would have been 48 minutes so was there
a miscommunication or did plans change
anybody got a bead on that cuz I don't
feel like looking it up yeah so that
will now properly wrap it up Rosa what
were your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it a whole bunch of
stuff to do because there's buttons and
there's links including a link different
page you're out if you feel like
supporting this show and the things that
I
I am getting within spitting distance of
the goal range that would allow enable
me to get a new camera the one I use is
crazy old but in any case you know check
it out if you feel like supporting me
that way but if you don't don't sweat it
because you are the council and I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]